Musik Warum gibt's einen Flugmodus?
Das ist ja schon sehr speziell.
Es gibt keinen Zugmodus, es gibt keinen Schiffmodus, Mondmodus gibt's, Mond und Flug.
Sind das eigentlich zwei Dinge, die unser Leben bestimmen?
Naja, naja gut.
Wie geht's dir, Florentin? Laufen wir schon?
Warte.
Du hast nur dir was du trinken mitgebracht und mir nicht.
Lass mich noch kurz diese Mail zu Ende schlagen. Nur diese eine Mail, lass sie mich schreiben schnell, sie wird nicht viel verändern in dieser Welt. Aber sie hilft, dass ich mich besser fühle, sie hilft, mich zu fühlen, als hätte ich was geschafft an diesem verregneten Sonntagmorgen. Anne Scene. gute 30 Minuten, eine fantastische Gags. Mein Name ist Valentin Will und mir gegenüber sitzt Stefan Tizze. Tizze, herzlich willkommen. Der Titzschlag hat wieder zugeschlagen, denn Stefan war im Urlaub. Haha, Stefan war im Urlaub, du hast dich ja wirklich diesmal richtig gut gehen lassen, du warst unterwegs, du hast die ganze Welt bereits. Ich war in Dänemark, auf Teneriffa, ich war auf Ibiza, ich war auf Madagaskar, das war schön. Wow. Ja, da fallen einem die Kokosnüsse aber auch auf den Kopf.
Ja, also ich habe meinen Urlaub ganz moderat verbracht, schön ausgeruht, schön mal ein bisschen die Gags zu mir kommen lassen.
Und ist was gekommen?
Nee, aber du, bei dir?
Ich mag es nicht, wie du diese Blowjob-Geste hier schon direkt die ganze Zeit hast,
diese Arme hinter dem Kopf verschränkt, einfach dieses Komm, gib's mir, Baby. Ne, das ist meine Zurücklehnen-Geste. Du, wir müssen ja auch über Pokémon sprechen und so heute, das ist klar. Wir kommen nicht drum herum. Also die Leute erwarten ja von unserem Nerd-Podcast, wie Quotenmeter es schon mal bezeichnet hat, erwarten die halt natürlich auch jetzt dann die Nerd-Themen. Hast du da ein paar Gags vorbereitet? Hast du viele Pokémon gesammelt im Urlaub? Ja, ein paar, 70 Stück glaube ich. Ich habe 72 gesehen, 70 gefangen. Zwei, weiß ich nicht, was da in mich gefahren ist. Ich habe auch Pokémon gesammelt, das hat mich ein bisschen frustriert. Ich habe immer tolle Pokémon gesehen, die in der Nähe sind, und dann ist es meine App abgestürzt, und dann waren sie nicht mehr da, das war sehr frustrierend. Aber finden Sie auch, dass Pokémon-Namen oft wirken, als hätte man die Lizenzen der echten Tiere nicht bekommen. Ja, so ein bisschen. Also es ist so ein bisschen so, ich hatte damals ein Spiel, das hieß David Beckham Soccer, das war für den ersten Game Boy, gab es ein Spiel und die haben halt nicht alle Lizenzen von Namen bekommen, also hat Ballok gegen Philipp Lohm gespielt und so und auch die Namen der Teams waren nicht richtig und die Farben waren so ein bisschen daneben, es war alles so ein bisschen off. Peter Kahn. Tatsächlich, und ich finde, eigentlich wirken die Pokémon doch auch so, als hätte man die Namen von Littinia nicht bekommen. Es ist ein bisschen seltsam und das Interessante ist, dass es bei World of Warcraft auch so. Also ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es da so ist, aber da gibt es dann, du läufst dann durch die Savanne und dann siehst du... Durch die Savonne? Zum Beispiel siehst du einen Giraffe, Geier und Zebra. Und dann denkst du dir, was, haben die jetzt die Lizenzrechte für das Wort Zebra nicht bekommen? Mit V oder mit B, weil das V ist ... Mit V, Zebra. Ja, das ist aber neben dem B auf der Tastatur, der hat es eher verschrieben. Oh mein Gott, der ist so ein kreativer. Zebra, das ist ja genial. Ja, das war geplant, ja, genau, genau wie ich denn die Himmel ... Statt Hummeln, da funktioniert das nicht, weil Himmel auch ein Wort ist. Ja gut, naja. Ihr merkt es ein bisschen, wir sind noch ein bisschen, wir haben noch ein bisschen Staub in den Augen, wir sind noch ein bisschen zu ausgeschlafen, vielleicht zu satt, zu vollgefressen, zu rund, um in diese neue, schnelllebige Podcastwelt zu kommen. Eine Menge hat sich getan, Podcast Deutschland verändert sich, viele neue Podcasts sprießen aus der Erde, wir haben euch mal zusammengetragen. Ja, wie die Sexperten zum Beispiel. Die Sexperten haben uns leider überholt, das war ja ursprünglich auch ein Titel, den wir diesem Podcast geben wollten eigentlich, sollte ja ursprünglich mal ein reiner Sexpodcast werden. Aber Steffen, was sind denn deine 17 Podcasts, die du empfehlen würdest, für alle, die jetzt Bock haben? Ich glaube, jetzt kommen deine 17 Sextipps. Deineblingsstellungen, ja. Ich habe mich gefreut, dass du nochmal abgebogen bist in Richtung Podcast. Also, auf meinem Platz 11 fange ich mal an einfach jetzt. Einfach mal so. Rudis Podcast. Ja, dann Freds lustige Ulkstunde, finde ich, ist eine grosse Bereicherung für die deutsche Podcastwelt. Ich finde es geil, dass es Fred schafft, auch völlig alleine eine richtig gute Show zu machen. Also er gibt ja Fitness-Tipps, aber auch mit so einem gewissen Comedy-Einschlag. Ich finde, er macht das richtig gut. Also Freds Ulk-Bude, glaube ich, kann sich hier wirklich sehen lassen oder hören lassen, je nachdem. Tom und Gerd, die beiden Bauarbeiter, die immer lustige, sich immer Sprüche ausdenken, wie sie Frauen anbaggern von Baustellen, dachte die erst, ist so ein Konzept, was man schon mal gehört hat, aber wie die jetzt dann neu aufrollen, auch mit so einem neuen, modernen Approach, finde ich ganz toll. Das ist meine persönliche Nummer acht. Platz neun der Krasscast, Udo und Jürgen haben sie wieder zusammengesetzt, reden über alles, was das Herz begehrt, Vergaser, Felgen, da geht's richtig zur Sache. Die neue Folge geht ja komplett nur um die besten und feinsten Steaks. Cool.
Hat mir richtig gut gefallen.
Der Thüren-Podcast finde ich ganz abgefahren als vom Thüren-Verkäufer, der jede Woche eine neue Tür vorstellt, die im neuen Programm ist. Ganz abgefahren, also ein Konzept, wo ich dachte, what, erstmal, okay, man sich auf sich gehen lassen, braucht man auch ungefähr 80 Folgen, um reinzukommen, aber dann zahlt es sich aus. Aber wenn man reinkommt, dann ist man auch drin. Wenn man reinkommt, dann ist man drin, das ist cool. Das ist, glaube ich, auch sogar sein Slogan. Boden.de hat mir sehr gut gefallen, die besten Böden Deutschlands, immer sehr interessant, auch Klangerlebnisse werden da geboten und steht für mich auf festen Beinen. Fahnencast, natürlich, jede Woche neue Fahne, die Geschichte hinter den Flaggen, ganz tolle Sache. Und vor allem auch, hast du die, die zu den lokalen Flaggen gehört, die Folge? Nein, noch nicht.
Richtig geil, also dass man auch wirklich mal so ein bisschen in die Tiefe geht, so die Flaggen der
einzelnen Orte und Städte, dass man da richtig reingeht. Ich finde es ja immer toll, zum Beispiel
Bayern hat ja dieses Drachenmuster, dieses Drachenmuster, also mit diesen kleinen Pentatonik, Phonics, mit diesen Polyphonen, so, und dann ist er weiss und blau und dann hieß es immer, ja, weil der Himmel über Bayern weiss und blau ist. Dann bin ich mir so, warum sind nicht alle Flaggen weiss und blau, die meisten Himmel sind immer weiss und blau. Das ist so eine scheisse Erklärung, so ist dann irgendwie in Frankreich der Himmel grün, oder was? Was war denn von Ebersbach dein Heimatdorf? Was war denn da? Weissgrün. Weissgrün und ein Wildschwein davor. Hm, echt? Ja, ja, der Ebersberg, also der Eber, das ist die Männischweine. Der Ebersberg. Ja, der Ebers. Ich habe einen Wildschwein im Forst gesehen.
Ich war jetzt in meiner Heimat, ich war in Ebersberg unterwegs. Ebersberg, da Forst. Forst. Wir hatten mal übrigens Herrn Forst, der unser Biolehrer war. Was ich auch lustig finde, dass die Leute so heißen und ihrem Fach direkt zuzuordnen sind. Hattet ihr als Biosphäre den Wald oder den See? Ich glaube, im Bio-Unterricht gibt es so eine Unterrichtslektion, so Biosphäre, so wie die verschiedenen Tiere und Pflanzen miteinander interagieren. Ich weiss noch, wie unser Bio-Lehrer, Herr Kern, finde ich auch nicht schlecht, zu uns kam und sagt, ja, pass mal auf, normalerweise muss man ja immer den Wald machen, im Lehrplan steht Wald, aber ich dachte mir, der Wald ist so stinklangweilig.
Ich habe für euch mal ein richtiges Schmankerl rausgekramt, was der richtig heisse Scheiss. Die Tundra. Haltet euch fest, dieses Jahr, es wird der See. Also, what the fuck, See, Alter! Und es war halt das fucking langweiligste der Welt, und du hast halt Enten und Würmer und Scheiss, Grundeln, Bimseln, die Bissell, der Knotterich, der Trobeldur, die Fnikito, der Bilzweisler, der Schmauchbachler und das Pummelhofer Level 16, was es dann im Büro schaut. Haben wir alles dabei. Wir haben auf jeden Fall den See durchgenommen und es war unfassbar. Das war richtig gut. Gute Erfahrung. Was sollst du da vorsagen, Ebersberg, wo ich dich hier rüde und da braucht man das. Ebersberg, ich habe mit dem Ebersberger Forst, grösste aneinander hängende Forstlandschaft Europas. Vielleicht, nein, wahrscheinlich nicht. Weiß ich nicht. Habe ich einen Wildschwein gesehen, ja, das war ganz interessant. Ich war mit dem Pfarrer unterwegs im Ebersberger Forst. Ich bin ganz gespannt, wo diese Wildschweine an der Dote jetzt hinführen.inander sind. Und dann bin ich so gefahren, also im vierter Gang, klar, man ist unterwegs, man hat einen gewissen Zahn drauf, ja, da lasse ich mich auch nicht lumpen. Und dann fährt man so die Bäume, die Fichten, die Tannen, die Buchen, die Walden, ja, die Weiden, die rauschen an einem vorbei, unter einem der Kies, die Steine schlagen aus nach links und rechts, man hat ein gutes Tempo drauf. Und plötzlich sieht man so in 100 Metern Entfernung, in 100 Metern Entfernung läuft ein Wildschwein auf den Weg. Ich natürlich in die Eisen, direkt gegangen, erstmal schön mein Gefähr zum Anhalten gebracht, Stillstand, Stopp, gesagt, Stopp. Dann schön den Pokéball rausgeholt? Abgestiegen, Tür auf, habe ich noch Massabelle und, nee, das Wildschwein hat mich angeschaut, ich habe das Wildschwein angeschaut und das war so ein Moment, dass man weiß noch nicht genau, wer vor wem Angst... Ach so, ich dachte so der gegenseitigen Respekt so, einfach so... Nee, so ein... Nee, man guckt sich an und man weiß noch nicht genau, wer vor wem Angst haben soll. Das ist so, wie wenn du nur Ausländer siehst und du denkst, okay, vielleicht hat er auch Angst vor mir, ich könnte ja Nazi sein. Man weiss es nicht genau so, wer jetzt Angst haben soll und wer nicht. Richtig. So war das bei dem Wildschwein auch und man guckt sich halt so ein paar Sekunden an und denkt sich, na gut, dich würde ich schaffen eigentlich, würde ich dich schaffen, ich weiss es nicht, würde man in einem Kampf Fahrrad, wie nimmt das Schwein jetzt mein Fahrrad auf, denkt es, ich hätte Rotterbeine oder so? Ich hätte das Fahrrad, also fertig schnell. Nein, nicht mein Problem, nicht mein Kampf. Armade her! Und weg. Er ist dann weggelaufen und ich bin weitergefahren. Du hattest, glaube ich, dein Instinkt war nicht schlecht, diese Anekdote anzuzweifeln, von Anfang an. Es hat nicht so hundertprozentig funktioniert. Aber es ist ja auch so, dass Haie zum Beispiel gar nicht, Also Menschen kommen gar nicht in der Welt von Haien vor. Und wenn du ... Es ist immer dieser Urban-Myth oder, weiss nicht, Sea-Myth, ist, dass man quasi ... Wenn man Blut ... Wenn Blut im Wasser ist, das Haie dann ankommen. Und das stimmt, die können irgendwie einen Tropfen Blut auf, weiss nicht wie viele Kubikkilometer Entfernung wittern, aber halt Menschenblut nicht.
Ach was.
Ja, wirklich?
Das ist Wissen to go.
Wissen to swim eigentlich.
Auch im neuen Highcast könnt ihr das auch alles wahrnehmen.
Ja.
Highclass, Highcast.
Auf meinem Platz drei.
Der Highcast, hat mir richtig gut gefallen.
Dein Platz zwei.
Mein Platz zwei, die Stiesel-Show.
Roland Stiesel lässt es mal wieder krachen und fährt die besten Gigs und Gags auf, die das Land zu bieten hat. Leider abgesetzt. Von wem eigentlich? Das war mir immer ein Riesel. Das ist eine gute Frage. Wir haben ja auch schon Drohnen bekommen, dass wir abgesetzt werden. Ja, aber ich mir immer frage, ist es Spam, ist es ein lustiger Gag? Wir wurden bei WordPress neulich überlaufen mit lauter ... Ja, vor allem das Interessante ist, wir haben ja ganz viele Folgen, ich glaube 70 Folgen, und 99,9% der gesamten Spam-Kommentare kommen nur bei der Folge Avocado. Da kommen wirklich fast alle Spam. Das ist so seltsam, also ich weiss nicht, woran es liegt. Ja,am oder sehr einfach zu erklären. Ja das werden die durch irgendwelche, ja das sind die zwei Möglichkeiten. Weiss ich nicht, das sind immer die zwei Möglichkeiten. Die Aufmerksamkeit des Gerichtssaals war auf Anwalt Titze. Ja da fallen sie einfach vor, ich habe nur laut nachgedacht. Oder halt nicht, scheisse. Und das ist ganz seltsam, vielleicht haben die irgendwie solche Wortfilter gedönselt, dass sie dann irgendwie so sinnvolle Worte rausfiltern. Und Avocado, ich glaube, der eine, na, aber wir haben auch Möbel und so. Und Möbel ist eigentlich schon Möbel, Nübel, diese ganzen lustigen Möbel, diese Umlaute. Die stimmt, Umlaute können ein Problem sein, ja, das ist vielleicht ein, Träume haben wir auch Schlag. Aber ich weiß nicht, Avocado funktioniert auf jeder Sprache halt, ist ein, ich glaube, weiss ich nicht, Avocado, ich glaube, es funktioniert, also du sprichst auch viele an, Avocado hat keine eng gefasste Zielgruppe und die wollen ja möglichst viele Leute erreichen. Also du meinst, Leute, die Avocados essen, die haben auch Potenzprobleme. Ja, und da könnten Kinder sein, könnten Erwachsene sein, können 19 sein, können Hunde sein, können 80 sein. Alle essen Avocados, auch in jedem Land. Ich finde es okay. Ich finde es nicht schlimm. Ich habe mal für die Arbeiterwohlfahrt gearbeitet, habe ich Kinder betreut, Ferienbetreuung habe ich gemacht. War echt absurd, weil ich habe mir eine Rauchvergiftung ein... Also mir ging es wirklich schlecht, weil ich viel Rauch eingeatmet habe, weil... Weil es gebrannt hat, die ganze Zeit, mein Gott, was ist das für Arbeitgeber?
Ja, und Kinder sind sehr schlecht im Löschen, also nur falls ihr das liest, da kann man sich nicht darauf verlassen, weil wir wollten mit Lupen, wollten wir Sachen zum Anbrennen bringen und ich habe mich da so reingesteigert und habe dann so in diese ganzen Heuballen gepustet und alles und habe dann so viel Rauch eingeatmet, weil irgendwann geht es dann auch nicht mehr um die Kinder und den pädagogischen Effekt, sondern man muss dann wirklich einfach nur Ärger. Nur dass du mehr verbrennst als Kinder.
Es geht einfach wirklich darum, es einfach zu machen.
Deswegen mein Tipp, wenn ihr so ein Heu... Weil irgendwann geht es dann auch nicht mehr um die Kinder und den pädagogischen Effekt, sondern man muss dann wirklich einfach nur Ärger. Ich glaube, dass du mehr verbrennst als Kinder.
Deswegen mein Tipp, wenn ihr so einen Heuballen habt oder so einen Strohballen oder so trockenes Gras oder sowas und da habt ihr es geschafft, eine Glut herzustellen, dann dreht diesen Ballen um, sodass die Glut unten ist und pustet von unten drauf. Dann atmet ihr a, kein Rauch ein und das Feuer kann sich nach oben ausbreiten und irgendwann brennt es dann.
Dann habt ihr es zwar noch brennend in der Hand und euren Aufsichtsbefehl missfolgt, aber trotzdem so funktioniert es. Also kleiner Tipp, dreht es um, so dass die Glut unten ist und pustet von unten und zündet so die Flamme. Aber wie ist es mit deiner Autorität, wo du gerade dabei warst? Also ich habe ein Riesenproblem, das ist mir aufgefallen. Ich war nämlich neulich, wir haben für ein neues Projekt, haben wir Autoren gesucht und ich durfte in Bewerbungsgesprächen sitzen, weil du im Urlaub warst und alle anderen auch. Und dann fiel einem auch, scheiße, die Termine fallen genau in aller Weltsurlaub, oh nein, Stefan ist ja da. Das heißt, in Bewerbungsgesprächen haben nur du und der Mergen Fox-Aussteller gemacht, einfach die beiden wichtigsten Mitarbeiter der Bewerber. Und dann war es halt vorher so, der erste Bewerber kam mit mir um 15 Uhr, sonst war hier nichts los, also bin ich dann davor einfach durch die Stadt gelaufen und habe mir auch irgendwann ein Slush-Eis geholt, so ein blaues Slush-Eis. Und ich hatte halt meine ganze Lippen, das ist mir erst später aufgefallen, als ich dann zum Bewerbungsgerichtäch gefahren bin, meine Lippen waren komplett blau, meine Zunge, mein ganzer Mundraum, war einfach so strahlend blau und ich dachte mir, also was haben jetzt Bewerber, hilft denen das jetzt im Bewerbungsgespräch, wenn der Typ, der da sitzt mit ihnen und auch fragt, was stellen sie sich für ein Gehalt vor, einfach eine wahnsinnig blaue Zunge hat. Also hilft denen das, weil es die Nervosität nimmt? Was mache ich hier? So ein Ohrenstäbchen, guckt ihr doch aus dem Ohr, einfach so komplett so, was ist das für dich? Soll ich wirklich dem jetzt sagen, was ich mir für ein Gehalt vorstelle? Ist das ein Riesenprank, wo sind die Kameras? Was löst das denn den Bewerber aus? Zumal ja, also ohne dir jetzt nahezutreten zu wollen, du ja auch im unblauen Modus relativ wenig Autorität ausstrahlst, um ganz ehrlich zu sein. Mit meinen verweinten Augen immer. Glaub ich, meinen Augen, ja, das braucht es glaube ich gar nicht immer so sehr, dass du dann deine Autorität noch versuchst, künstlich runterzusetzen. Okay, das hilft mir jetzt, also meinst du, ist es nicht so viel schiefgegangen? Du bist ein nahbarer Typ, auf jeden Fall. Auch wenn du ihm vielleicht ein bisschen arg viel Gehalt zugesprochen hast, dann müssen wir auch nochmal drüber reden, aber... Ja gut, er war ein Slush-Eis-Fan, ich konnte nicht anders, da habe ich ihm sehr viel angeboten. Ich weiß, er hatte auch ein Slush-Eis in der Hand, er kam rein und so, beide haben den Mundblau und so. Aber ich habe auch wahnsinnig viel Angst vor, also ich könnte das glaube ich gar nicht, so Avro, so einen Scheiss, weil ich habe auch wahnsinnig Angst vor Kindern. Auch wenn ich jetzt Pokémon Go gespielt habe, irgendwie, durch die Stadtaufen bin und überhaupt irgendwo ein Logmodel gezündet wurde, und dann denke ich mir, geil, das ist, also mein Gamer-Instinkt sagt mir, es macht nur Sinn, dass du da jetzt hingehst, aber meine Vernunft sagt mir, da werden dann dreizehnjährige coole Teenager sind, die auf Lunge rauchen können, die stehen dann da und dann komme ich da hin mit meinem Luftballon und mit meiner blauen Zunge und stelle mich dann da hin und will Smoggon fangen. Also es gibt in der Stadt so verschiedene Punkte, wo man Pokébälle sammeln kann und man kann an diesen Punkten dann so ein Lockmodul einsetzen. Was soll ich denn da? Eine Anmoderation, was Pokémon Go ist? Dass mehr Pokémon anzieht. Und es war bei uns beim Campen auch so, dass wir so einen Pokéstop hatten in der Nähe und halt die ganzen Kinder des Campingplatzes haben halt da ständig diese Köder ausgeworfen, dass mehr Pokémon kommen. Und man hat das halt gemerkt, man hat sich dann so awkward hingestohlen, und dann sassen da irgendwie zwei vierzehnjährige im Badeanzug und man sitzt dann so daneben und weiss gar nicht was. Im Badeanzug? Ja, die haben dann gebadet einfach am See, das war dann echt so unangenehm, weil man denkt sich dann so, ja scheiße. Ja, es ist halt immer geil, wenn es dann Orten ist, wo man auch sozial akzeptiert länger bleiben kann. bleiben bleiben kann also diese halbe stunde wie das log modul da bleibt ja bleiben kann ein kaffee zum beispiel
oder so oder halt ich glaube du lernst dich auch viele leute kennen oder es ist auch eine gute
möglichkeit leute anzusprechen wenn die halt dann da stehen und dann so cool danke fürs log
modul ja cool hast du auch ein smogger noch level 12 nein guck mal hier ich habe einen Smogger nach Level 12? Nein. Guck mal hier, ich habe einen Smog Mog. Wow, ich habe noch keins. Und 30 Minuten länger, weil das Logmodul noch 30 Minuten dauert. Das ist schwierig. Es ist auf jeden Fall cool, was diese App mit mir macht. Ich habe auch überlegt, joggen zu gehen, einfach mal, weil man da schnelle Kilometer zurücklegt, du kannst deine Eier ausbrüten, wenn du viel gehst, du kannst Dinge fangen und ich glaube, sonst würde ich niemals joggen. Das ist sowas, was mich, glaube ich, an Joggen bringt. Ich kann so nicht joggen gehen, weil ich habe kein Ziel. Du hast ja auch kein Ziel, dein Ziel ist es zu joggen, der Weg ist das Ziel. Kann man nicht auch einfach sein Handy immer hin und her werfen zwischen zwei Leuten und dann dadurch einfach Weg zurücklegen oder ist das zu schnell?
Das ist, wie gesagt, du, alle 60 Sekunden aktualisiert das und bildet dann den Punkt zwischen, also die Linie zwischen den beiden Punkten.
Und wenn du, auch wenn du eine ganz blöde Kurve gehst, so wie so die Saare-Schleife, wenn du die entlang gehst und dann halt aber leider genau so schnell bist, dass du halt quasi nur einfach zehn Meter zwischen dir und dem Anfangspunkt gegangen bist, 60 Sekunden, dann hast du halt nur zehn Meter zurückgelegt, statt die eigentlichen achtzehn Kilometer, die in der Zeit gelaufen bist. Du musst sehr schnell sein dafür. Ja, das ist ein Problem. Ja. Naja, und sonst? Ja, doch, ganz gut. Momentan ist es viel.
Es regnet sehr viel. Es regnet sehr viel. Es regnet viel, ein bisschen Musik hören. Du hast die neue Kopfhörer gekauft. Ach ja. Ich überlege mir auch die zu kaufen, diese Noise-Cancellation-Kopfhörer, die aus der Umgebung die Klang rausfiltern und bei dir sozusagen ausnullen und dadurch hörst du Umgebungsgeräusche nicht mehr. Und es ist eigentlich ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung, eigentlich so seine eigene Glaskammer sich bauen. Weil ich bin so oft einfach im ICE unterwegs und bin so viel Lärm ausgesetzt und solchen Vollspacken, wo man sich einfach denkt, warum kann man nicht genau wie Augen zumachen, einfach Ohren zumachen. Warum hat die Evolution nicht daran gedacht, einfach zu sagen, du kannst dir den Mund zumachen, du kannst dir Augen zumachen,, aber warum einfach nicht die Ohren einfach schliessen können? Feinde vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, Fressfeinde, so ganz abgabend die Gedanken. Ja, und die kannst du nicht sehen oder was? Nein. Oder nicht schmecken? Weil deine Augen zu sind. Ja, eben. Du kannst sie riechen vielleicht mal irgendwann in der Evolution. Ja, aber du kannst dir ja dazu entscheiden, deinen Sinn auszuschalten, den deinen Sichtsinn. Ja, jedenfalls sind das Kopfhörer, die sind wahnsinnig teuer. Und da wollte ich ja nochmal jetzt irgendwie sagen, ich finde es nicht toll, dass du mich jemals als Fehlkaufstefan inszenierst, auch mit der Plakatkampagne, die ein bisschen drüber war, und dann jetzt plötzlich mit Dingen einfach nachkaufst, sie funktionieren. Du kannst nicht, da musst du mir auch mal Dinge nachkaufen, die schlecht geklappt haben. Da musst du mir auch mal jetzt so Mangochips nachkaufen. Du bist halt so ein bisschen der Vorkoster. Also ich weiß, jeder zwanzigste Kauf von dir ist ein Erfolg.
Tötet mich.
Aber die neunzehn davor lasse ich die schön ins Messer laufen.
Ja.
Und dann, wie geht's deinem Hoverboard?
Ja, ist kaputt jetzt.
Davon hätte ich mir drei so Kopfhörer kaufen können.
Ja, das ist leider echt kaputt.
Aber versicherungsmäßig soll ich dich jetzt vielleicht nicht fragen, wie das funktioniert. Ja, vor allem, dass es ja China bezogen ist. Das ist natürlich auch ein bisschen schwierig. Wo bist du versichert? Wo bist du versichert? Aorta. Ja, akzeptiere ich. Das Coole ist einfach, dass du auch nicht so laut die Musik hören musst, weil du die Umgebungsgeräusche reduzierst. Und ich mittlerweile höre wahnsinnig laut Musik, weil die U-Bahn noch wahnsinnig laut ist. Und dann machst du immer lauter, lauter, lauter und das ist halt auch nicht gut für die Ohren. Ja, vor allem beim iPhone 5 hast du ja, wenn du die Lautstärke so hochregelst, wird dieser Regler irgendwann rot und zeigt dir an sehr laut. Also du machst gerade dein Gehör kaputt, was ich an sich ganz cool finde. Das ist psychologisch echt gut. Das ist wirklich gut. Also ich versuche dann auch immer, wenn ich eine Zeit lang höre und fahre in der ICE zum Beispiel, aktiv die Musik immer alle zehn Minuten wieder ein und runter zu regeln, weil du dich dann auch an die geringere Lautstärke wieder gewöhnst und dann dir gar nicht auffällt, dass es leiser wurde, aber man das ab und zu runter machen muss, weil es macht echt einen Unterschied, glaube ich, wenn du einfach vier Stunden lang mit fünf Punkten mehr einfach hörst, als wenn du fünf Punkte weniger hast, obwohl es für dich gar nicht so ein unterschiedliches Erfahren ist. Das ist psychologisch ein riesen Problem, weil diese Kopfhörer zum Beispiel jetzt, die sind leiser ein bisschen als meine In-Near-Kopfhörer, sind so Over-Ear-Kopfhörer, weil ihr die gerade nicht seht, gerade, weil ihr woanders zugeschaltet habt. Und ihr könntet sie auch nicht hören, weil sie haben Noise-Cancellation, von daher. Und diese Dinger sind ein bisschen leiser, das heisst, ich habe mehr Striche auf meinem Handy, wenn ich die Lautstärke einstelle. Das ist psychologisch ein Riesener, die sind dann halt, die sind einfach leiser vom Werk aus, das heisst, sie schaden meinen Ohren weniger beim gleichen Stand der Striche, aber trotzdem traue ich mich nicht, die lauter zu machen, weil ich mir denke, das ist zu viel. Ja, vor allem, aber ist nicht auch Musik unterschiedlich laut? Also sind nicht unterschiedliche Genres, also Metal ist doch bestimmt lauter als jetzt so ein Bach-Violinen-Konzert, oder? Nee, die sind ja alle gleich gemastert auf einer coolen Dezibelzahl. Auf einer coolen Dezibelzahl. Auf eine cool runde Dezibelzahl, die Spaß macht. Auf eine coolen Dezibelzahl. Ich merke, du wirst ausgebildet in dem Bereich. Ich habe eine wahnsinnige Dokumentation bei Netflix gesehen, total geil, wo ein Mathematiker versucht hat, alle Sachen der Erde in Mathematik zu münzen. Und das ist halt echt interessant, weil alles in Mathematik erklärbar ist, auch zum Beispiel Musik und warum Dinge gut klingen, haben wir uns auch mal gefragt. Ich habe mich im Urlaub auch mal gefragt, warum hört man eigentlich die Musik, die man hört, warum haben andere Leute einen anderen Musikgeschmack?
Das ist ja zum einen natürlich, wenn Leute rebellieren wollen, hören sie Punk, weil die Eltern nicht mögen und so, aber das führt ja nicht dazu, dass man was mag, es führt dazu, dass man was hört, oder vielleicht auch ein T-Shirt trägt oder so, aber es führt ja nicht dazu, dass man es wirklich mag. Ah doch, glaube ich schon. Im gewissen, irgendwann vielleicht doch, weil man das dann immer hört, weil man sich daran gewöhnt.
Und es ist wirklich so, dass halt, wenn du ein C spielst, ein höheres C spielst, also eine Oktave spielst, dann sind die Frequenzen, das heißt die Wellenlänge, ist halt eins zu zwei. So sind die halbiert. Genau. Und das ist halt, also mathematisch, je runder etwas ist, desto einfacher ist es wahrzunehmen, desto gesünder klingt es auch fürs Ohr. Und zum Beispiel ist dann eine Quinte, also auch irgendwann so typisch konsonante Sachen, Mozart, die ganzen Sachen früher, die waren relativ einfach zu dechiffrieren, halt einfach sehr konsonante Musik. Das ist sehr einfach, das sind sehr kurze Vielfachen, das ist zu vier im Verhältnis, eins zu zwei von Wellenlängen her. Und deswegen hören wir das halt gerne und gut und deswegen ist es auch einfach zunehmendliche Klassik zum Beispiel. Es ist total interessant und Musik ist einfach sehr, sehr einfach mathematisch zu erklären, warum wir etwas gut finden. Und es ist ja auch einfach, also je mehr du dich mit Mathe beschäftigst, desto einfacher wirken irgendwann komplexe Formen und desto lieber magst du immer noch komplexere Formeln, weil du andere schon satt bist. Die hast du schon verstanden, die hast du schon gelöst irgendwann mal und dann willst du dich an neue Dinge wagen. Genauso ist es mit der Musik ja auch. Je mehr du dich mit Klassik und Jazz und so beschäftigst, desto mehr fängst du irgendwann an, das auch zu mögen und komplexere Musik zu mögen. Was ich meine, ich verstehe, also wenn jetzt eine Geige ein A spielt und ein Klavier ein A, den selben Ton, dann ist es ja dieselbe Wellenlänge. Selbe Wellenlänge, ja.
Aber trotzdem kannst du ja unterscheiden, ob das jetzt ein Klavier oder eine Geige ist. Also wie wird denn dann diese Information gespeichert?
Worin in der Welle ist denn die Art …
Das Ausgangsmedium ist ja ein anderes.
Aber was heisst das denn für die Welle? Ist dann die Welle … Ich meine, es ist ja dieselbe Welle, weil es ist ja derselbe Ton. Ja. Aber warum kannst du denn einen Unterschied hören? Ja, weil etwas anderes die Welle auslöst, würde ich jetzt sagen. Also wenn ein Blech mit 440 Hertz schwingt oder deine Stimmlippen mit 440 Grad schwingen … Das ist auch hauchzart vorbei. Das heißt, es wird Stimmlippen. Ja? Das weiß ich, Gott sei Dank. Nice. Ja, auch geil, so ein Finte, wo man denkt, es wäre knapp vorbei. Und dann guckt man es nach und dann ist es auch richtig, ja, sehr guter Gag. So viel dazu, kurz musiktheoretisch, fand ich sehr interessant. Das sind diese Fragen, die ich mir gestellt habe, als ich im Urlaub war, in der Wüste Nairobi und dann mir überlegt habe, was sind noch Dinge, die mich interessieren und dann habe ich versucht, die zu beantworten für mich und mit Hilfe von Netflix-Serien und dann dachte ich mir, komm, bringst du das Wissen mal an die Leute. Was hast du herausgefunden im Urlaub? Hast du dir Fragen gestellt? Nichts, nee, nicht viel. Hast du was gelesen, hast du ein Buch gelesen? Ich habe ein Buch gelesen, ja. Bist du jemanden, der nicht auf dem Strand liegt und dann so ein Buch liest? Ich habe immer meinen Kindel unterm Arm und liest dann so ein bisschen. Du bist ein sehr grosses Kind. Ja. Und nee, ich habe über den Ersten Weltkrieg gelesen. Welche Schlacht fandst du da besonders? Wer da ... Und das ist lustig, dass du es jetzt in diesem Kontext erzählst. Nein, du hast mich gefragt und ich habe geantwortet, es tut mir leid. Wie wahnsinnig macht das, wenn Running Gags vom Publikum aufgegriffen werden? Wenn es ohne Kontext aufgegriffen wird, macht es schon wahnsinnig. Ich habe nichts gegen Running Gag. Running Gag ist okay. Aber wenn es ohne Kontext auf... Also wenn jetzt wirklich jemand auf der Strasse zu dir rennt und sagt, wer da, dann ist es nervig, weil dann ist es einfach, es ist auch kein Gag mehr, sondern es ist einfach nur Wiederholung.
Aber wenn es irgendwie im Kontext … Grüßen nicht Menschen mit Werda?
Nein, aber wenn mir jemand einfach nur eine Twitter-Nachricht schreibt mit dem Wort Werda ausrufezeichen, dann ist es halt nichts.
So, aber wenn es in einem neuen Kontext als Running Gag, ein Running Gag ist ja immer noch ein Gag, es ist ja nicht nur Running, es ist ja nicht nur Wiederholung an sich, es ist ja nicht nur, man rennt dem ja hinterher. Ich nehme einfach einen Witz vor, der einfach versucht, ans Ziel zu kommen und die ganze Zeit, ich glaube der... Nein, es muss trotzdem noch ein Gag sein, will ich damit sagen, dann nervt es auch nicht, dann ist es auch okay, dann kann man es auch machen, mein Gott. Nee, schön, ich wollte nur fragen, finde ich nur interessant, weil du jetzt auch neuerdings nämlich konfrontiert wärst, zum ersten Mal in deinem Leben, mit etwas, was du an die Leute gegeben hast und die finden das gut und so gut, dass sie es immer aufgreifen wollen und zeigen wollen, dass sie es verstanden haben, dass sie es auch lustig finden und dann wieder an dich herantragen. Das ist ja ganz, das ist ja ganz menschlich. Ja, waren wir beim Podcast so viel auch, aber mehr auch nicht. Stimmt, genau. Das alleine einfach zu benennen, ist kein Gag, das ist nicht lustig. Wenn man einfach nur sagt, gute Folge, mehr aber auch nicht, das ist nicht lustig, weil es einfach nur eine Wiederholung. Aber wenn man es in einem neuen Kontext irgendwie sinnvoll einbauen würde, in irgendwas Neuem, damit ein Gag macht, dann ist es cool. Mir ist das passiert. Jetzt möchte ich kurz, ich möchte das kurz erklären. Ist es soweit? Nee, das ist die Fehlkauf-Rubrik, wo wir gerade von einem guten Kauf gesprochen haben, den ich getätigt habe, jetzt zu einem weniger gut gelaufenen. Und zwar, es war ja sehr warm zwischendurch im Sommer. Es war sehr warm und dann dachte ich mir, ist mir aufgefallen etwas, was mich schon, was ich schon lange mit mir rumtrage, ich liebe Kratzeis. Ich bin ein riesen Kratzeisfan. Und damit meine ich nicht diese länglichen Tüten, wo man das rausschieben muss, sondern wirklich die Becher, die man einfriert und dann hat man so einen kleinen Plastiklöffel, der man abbricht, das ist ganz toll. Die habe ich jetzt vor ein paar Wochen gerade das allererste Mal in meinem Leben überhaupt gegessen. Ich habe mein gesamtes Leben noch nie Kratzeis gegessen, jetzt erst vor ein paar Wochen und es ist großartig. Und bei mir in der Nachbarstadt von der Heimat, wer das produziert? Bussi. Ach was? Da gibt es die Bussi-Bär. Du bist ja in der Nähe von Bussi? Ja, Bussi ist Berg Carmen, das ist die verfeindete Stadt von Carmen, ist Berg Carmen. Und da gibt es so verschiedene Bassen, Terrymore, Terrymoo und die aufeinander zulaufen. Und im Berg Carmen, das Mordor von Carmen, steht quasi das Bussi-Werk, so ein großes qualmendes Werk.
Ja, so tiefschwarzer Rauch und Schleim und ja.
Und ich wohne in Köln, ich hätte es da, die machen auch Werk verkauft, da kaufen können, weil ich, also das ist, ich fand es irgendwie blöd im Kiosk zu kaufen, weil ich fand es ein bisschen unangenehm, weil ich gesagt, da dachte ich mir, da kannst du immer noch eins kaufen, ich wollte sehr viel Kratzeis haben. Und dann habe ich mir überlegt, man kann ja bei Amazon mittlerweile sehr viel bestellen. Dann habe ich mir bei Amazon Kratzeis bestellt. Leider hatten die nicht irgendwie 20 oder so, sondern 400. Und dann habe ich mir, da habe ich mir dann gut, da dachte ich mir, die sind da sehr billig, die kosten nur 20 Euro dann da irgendwie. Dann habe ich mir 400 Kratzeis bestellt. Da dachte ich mir, okay, das kommt dann ungefähr übermorgen, da bin ich ja Gott sei Dank da. Und dann kann ich das auch annehmen, weil das wäre echt unangenehm, wenn ich dafür irgendwo hinlaufen muss und es abholen muss. Es kam, wie es kommen musste, ich war nicht da, als das Kratzeis angeliefert wurde. Es war sogar keine Karte im Briefkasten, aber ich habe eine Mail bekommen, dass mein Paket angekommen sei und bei der Post abgegeben wurde.
Und da dachte ich mir, okay, dann habe ich da angerufen bei der BRL, weil ich dachte, können die das nicht wieder vorbeibringen und so. Und dann meinten die, nee, da ist nicht mal was schiefgegangen, gehen Sie mal zur Post. Das tropft das Paket. Und dann dachte ich mir schon, fuck, bitte ey, nicht dabei, also bei allem kann man was schiefgegangen, aber nicht bei den fucking 400 Kratzer, die ich mir bestellt habe. Ich bin also zur Post gelaufen, hatte dann nur halt keine Karte dabei, sondern nur meinen Ausweis.
Und dann hat der nur meinen Namen gesehen, Tiese hat mich angeguckt,
also von meinem Ausweis runter und dann hochgeguckt zu mir, ja, das Paket ist da.
Und ich habe so schon hinter mir, ich guckte so eine Riesenschlange hinter mir,
natürlich bei der Post immer, fuck, was ist passiert, ja, ich hol's mal.
Und dann ist er weggegangen, ich höre immer so ein kratzendes Geräusch, dann hat er einfach so eine grosse Postwanne geholt und dann drinnen lag da mein Paket und dann meinte er, ja, das ist ausgelaufen, ich weiß nicht, was die da bestellt haben. Und dann ist es bei denen halt ausgelaufen. Und dann hat er halt eine riesige Wanne, wo halt so eine bunte Mischung aus sehr vielen Kratzeis drin war. Und dann hat er so hingeschoben. Und es war mir mega unangenehm, weil alle haben sich auch gefragt, was ist das für ein Typ, was hat er bestellt? Und dann habe ich halt im Laden verkündet, ich habe sehr viel Kratzeis bestellt. Weil ich mir dachte, ich muss das irgendwie rechtfertigen, was denkt ihr, was das so ist? Aber wie gross war denn das Paket? Das muss ja riesig gewesen sein. Es war schon gross. Also die sind ja nicht so gross und die kann man auch gut lagern, aber es war schon so, sagen wir mal, die Hälfte von mir. Aber warum laufen die denn aus? Die sind doch in Bechern drin. Ja, aber die sind nicht so dicht, das sind ja sehr dünne Becher. Und augenscheinlich, weiss nicht, hat mal jemand irgendwie dagegen gehauen oder so und dann ... Ich hasse Krassers. Und dann, ja, war war da dieses grosse Paket mitten im Laden, was ausgelaufen war.
Und dann habe ich gefragt, ja, was macht man denn bei sowas?
Ich meine, ich kann das ja nicht mitnehmen, weil das ja einfach so ein triefendes, buntes Paket mittlerweile war.
Und dann meinte er ja, ja, Sie können die Annahme verweigern.
Und das fand ich dann so cool, dass ich ganz laut gesagt habe, ja, ich verweigere hiermit die Annahme.
Und dann war es dann, ja, dass es würde, dass, ich dachte irgendwie, cool, ich muss unterschreiben oder so. Und dann habe ich da gestanden, habe mich so grinsend da umgeguckt, weil ich das cool fand, die Annahme zu verweigern. Und dann hat er gesagt, ja, dann, Sie können jetzt gehen. Also, ich weiß nicht, warum Sie noch hier stehen, aber dann konnte man einfach gehen. Dann habe ich damit die Annahme verweigert, habe das Geld zurückbekommen und alles cool. Aber echt unangenehm. Also echt unangenehm, was ausgerechnet bei diesem Paket dann dazu führt. Ja, aber du kannst ja damit rechnen, dass es schmilzt. Also hast du in Kauf genommen, dass es schmilzt? Nein, die werden ja flüssig geliefert. Ach so, und die packst du dann alle ein? So, dann frierst du die ein. Dann dachte ich mir, die werden ja nicht schlecht, weil es ist hauptsächlich Zucker und Farbstoff. Das kann man ja einfach liegen lassen mehrere Jahre und 400 werde ich in meinem meinem Leben vielleicht verbrauchen. Oder ich werde jetzt an notbedürftige Kinder oder so spenden einfach. 400, Alter, wenn du zwei Tage ein isst, dann sind es drei Jahre einfach. Ja, und dann stand die da halt so leider Gottes ausgelaufen in den Laden. Ich will so gut, dass die so eine Wanne haben, eine Wanne komplett vollgelaufen. Ich verweigere die Annahme, aber kann ich mich ganz kurz in die Wanne legen? Nur ganz kurz. Können sie die Wanne einfach einfrieren? Kann ich die zum Metzger nehmen, in so einen grossen Gefrierraum? Aber auch geil, ich dachte mir, allein dass sie sich so viel mit dem Paket beschäftigt haben, dass er schon meinen Namen gelesen hat und wusste, ja, ihr Paket ist da. Das ist angekommen. Dass sie den Namen Tietze schon mit, was hat der bestellt, was ist das für ein typisch verbundener Abend, das fand ich ganz interessant. Ja, das war die Kratzeis-Geschichte. Ach geil, nicht schlecht. Das war mein Soviel zu meinem Sommer. Und ich habe keinen Kratzeis im Endeffekt gegessen. Ach Gott, ach. Ich gebe dir mein Kratzeis aus. Ich glaube, ich fahre mal zu Bussi. Die, wie gesagt, machen auch Werkverkauf. Aber die machen auch so Fruchtgummis und so Gedöns, oder? Die machen nicht nur so ... Das weiss ich nicht genau. Trolli meinst du, glaube ich. Ja, Trolli, stimmt. Die haben alle so ganz lustige Namen. Die müssen wir mal ausfindig machen. Ich bin immer noch lange auf der Suche nach Trolli-Cheesecakes, der besten Südigkeit, die es jemals gab. Falls irgendwelche Leute da draußen an den Empfangsgeräten Informationen haben über Trolli-Cheesecakes, die es vor drei Jahren mal eine Zeit lang gab, zu kaufen, so Käsekuchenstückchen aus Fruchtgummi gedürzt. Wollen wir mal Behrung machen für Trolley? Das wäre, ich würde gerne machen. Eigentlich kriegt man das auch kostenlos. Subway hat sich ja bei uns gemeldet, also jemand hat geschrieben so, hey, geil, die machen die besten Sandwiches der Welt irgendwie at Subway und Subway hat geschrieben, ja, schreibt es mal eine Mail an irgendwie at Subwaydeutschland.de oder sowas. War das los? Ja, doch, über Twitter. Ich bin der Marketingchef des Podcasts. Ja, ich weiss, deswegen wundert es mich auch. Warum weiss ich davon gar nichts? Doch, auf Twitter hat jemand geschrieben, weil wir mal diese Tipps für das Sandwich, Subway Sandwich gemacht haben. Ja, ja. Und das hat jemand geschrieben und Subway Deutschland geaddet und dann haben die geschrieben, ja, schreibt es mal eine Mail, wir könnten wirklich von Subway gesponsert werden. Das ist bestimmt schon zwei Jahre her und wir haben einfach nicht reagiert, weil wir Trottel sind. Das ist bestimmt nicht mal zwei Monate her, also unsere Verhältnisse sind auch recht gut, glaube ich eigentlich. Das ist sehr pünktlich, ja cool. Also das wäre ja geil, dann können wir Werbung machen zum Beispiel für das neue Angebot, dass wenn man mit Pokémon Go Account dahingeht, kriegt man ab Level 20 ein kostenloses Sub und die Cookies sind auch immer gut. Drei Stück für 1,99. Ist ein fairer Preis, finde ich. Ist ein guter Preis. Ja. Geht doch mal vorbei. Subway. Eat fresh. Eat fresh. Or don't eat at all. Gute sehr seltsame Ton. Eat fresh. Echt? Gibt es da so ein Ton? Ja. Subway. Eat fresh. Ja. Sie sollten ja den Jingle für unsere Werbekampagne machen. Sie haben jetzt zwei Monate Zeit gehabt, haben Sie schon was ausgearbeitet? Wir haben ja schon mal gemeldet, die erste Version, die konnten wir nicht öffnen, da hieß es Dateien nicht öffenbar oder so. Ja, das war eine Pages-Datei. Richtig, genau, wir haben keine Pages-Leiter. Rückblickend auch fragwürdig, wie ich eine Ton-Datei in die Pages-Datei gekommen habe. Sorry dafür. Doch, jetzt sind wir auf jeden Fall da, der Marketingchef, das ist Herr Heinrichs, das ist der Marketingchef Deutschland, das ist Frau Paulsen, das ist die Internationaleiterin von PR und Marketing. Guten Tag, das ist Doktor Professor Richard Heinrichs. Wir springen zehn Minuten in die Zukunft, als alle Namen vorgestellt wurden. Das ist Eure Majestät Juliane die Dritte. Und das ist Maria Franz. Schützenkönigin, oder? Genau, und wir sind heute zu ihm gekommen, in ihre Bude, möchte man sagen. Ist ja schön, dass wir uns reingelassen haben. Ich hätte auch einfach zu euch kommen können, aber alles klar. Ich sehe da hinten schon das Keyboard, vielleicht fangen Sie einfach mal an. Also soll ich das nacheinander vorspielen, oder wollen Sie erst jeden einzelnennen hören und dann darauf was sagen oder wie? Genau, wir hatten die Intromelodie, den Jingle für die Kampagne Japan, den Jingle für die Kampagne Kanada, den Jingle für die Kampagne Deutschland und dann hatten wir noch überlegt, ob wir nicht für das Gewinnspiel vielleicht so eine Soundcue haben können, wo dann die User erraten können, was es denn ist. Fangen wir doch einfach mal mit dem Intro an. Okay, ich hab, was an Werbungen angelehnt wird immer, angehangen wird ganz am Ende. Da habe ich folgende Ideen. Genau, so ein Claim, so ein wiedererkennbarer, ja, sehr gut.
Als Vorlage haben sie mir Subway Eat Fresh genannt und da hatte ich jetzt folgende Idee, die ich für so nicht sehr gut fände, aber lassen Sie es einfach auf sich weggen.
Subway Eat Fresh. Das wäre Jingle Nummer eins. Ich habe noch zwei zur Auswahl. Ja, will auch mal rein. Subway, eat fresh. Ich spiele ihn noch mal ab. Subway, eat fresh. Das ist eine Kualumpa, da war ich im Urlaub auf Sardinien. Sie haben das jetzt mit Ihrem Mund gemacht, aber ist das, also imitieren Sie da ein Instrument, oder? Ja, wie gesagt, das sind einheimische Kirchkopfgesänge aus Sardinien. Also ich glaube, Frau Paul Olsen gefällt es ganz gut, Dr. Heinrichs ist ein bisschen, okay. Haben Sie das Intro, den Song? Ja, einen Moment. Da dachte ich mir, also ich bin nicht so gut in Instrumenten, habe ich ihn ja auch vorher geschrieben bei meiner Bewerbung, ich kann ganz gut mit Wörtern umgehen, deswegen habe ich einen kleinen Rap geschrieben. Oh. Würde ich jetzt gerne mal abspielen. Subway, wir haben die Sandwiches, wir machen euch klar, die Kerle und
die Bitches, wir haben die Zutaten, alle sind frisch und dann kommt's auf den Teller, aber bloß kein Fisch, wir haben nur Fleisch, wir hauen, ja da war ich noch nicht weiter gekommen, aber so dachte ich mir, dass man so einen kleinen Rap einfach startet, dass man halt immer Subway, weil Rap ist ja cool, ist ja Hip-Hop, Popkulturell, Gay, was die jungen Leute hören.
Ich dachte, dass man da immer Subway, weil Rap ist ja cool, Hip-Hop, Popkulturell, Gay, was die jungen Leute hören, dass ich dachte, dass man da irgendwie gleich in die Zielgruppe kommt. Das wäre so die Idee gewesen. Dann gibt es noch einen Classic Approach. Ist das Ihr Mitbewohner da hinten eigentlich? Nee, der liegt schon, ja, der ist bei der letzten WG-Party einfach liegen geblieben. Ah, okay. Da habe ich mich nicht getraut, nochmal anzufassen, Beweismittel und so. Der Klassik Approach. Da da da da da da Subway. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob da Copyright drauf ist, ob man da noch was machen kann, aber... Nee, die Rechte sind, die habe ich geklärt. Die gehören mir. Mein Name ist Stefan Beethoven, ich weiß nicht. Ach so, ach jetzt verstehe ich, das kommt jetzt zusammen. Ah, alles klar. Mein Urgrossvater, der war sehr alt geworden. Also, Doktor Heinrichs ist begeistert, er konnte, glaube ich, sich nicht helfen, ein bisschen mitzuwippen während des Raps. Das hatte auf jeden Fall einen guten Flow, also das war richtig cool. Ich fühl's cool. Das ist ja auch cool, also das ist ein cooler Typ, das merkt man ja glaube ich sofort. Und ich denke, wir sind alle recht zufrieden und würden sagen, dann gehen wir damit weiter in die nächste Phase. Und ja, genau, Prinzessin Bettina von Heinrichsen ist glaube ich auch ganz guter Dinge, sie nickt auf jeden Fall. Und ja, vielen Dank. Ich kann dir was zu trinken anbieten, ich meine, sie sind jetzt alle hier extra hergekommen, habe ich ganz vergessen jetzt, Gastgeber und so. Wollt ihr was zu trinken noch haben oder so? Ja, gerne, klar, natürlich. Einfach ein Wasser jetzt. Ja, oder haben sie vielleicht ein bisschen was fruchtigeres irgendwie, vielleicht ein Eis oder sowas? Ja, Kratzer, sie haben sehr viel Kratzer da. Achso, End scene. Okay. Wie kommt man aus Sketchen raus, das hat mich immer gefragt. Aber es ist auch selbst ein Podcast, die das nur machen, echt auch immer ein bisschen unangenehm anzuhören. Weil die meistens Musik, so coole Rockmusik, die dann einfällt. Ja. So weit, so gut. Ich habe neulich mein Pormonet vergessen in der Heimat, war dann eine Woche hier in Köln. Und das ist ganz schön furchtbar Führt nirgendwo hin, die Anekdote ist mir gerade nur eingefallen, da ich jetzt so richtig so ein Trauma, was ich jetzt mitgenommen habe, wenn man sein Portemonnaie vergisst, bist du eine Person oder ein Grater, du bist gar nichts, du bist niemand mehr, ich habe kein Bahnticket gehabt, kann mir aber auch keines kaufen, weil ich den Geld hatte. Wenn du hast noch das Foto von dir um den Hals hängen, so das ist ja noch nicht viel. Um meinen Schlüssel um den Hals hängen und so was man mit mir machen soll, wenn man mich bewusstlos auf den Strassen ranfindet, so eine Karte.
Auch auf dem Rücken tätowiert.
Fassen Sie mich bitte nicht an, seien Sie vorsichtig, erst die Hände waschen, bitte ziehen Sie mir keine peinlichen Sachen an, halt diese typische Karte. Und ja, du hast einfach verloren. Also kurzen Tipp nach draußen an euch, vergesst eure Kommunisten. Ich wurde beschossen.
Was? Ja.
Und zwar bin ich im ICE gefahren und dann plötzlich hieß es so, ja, ähm, äh.
Das war eine sehr reiserische Überschrift der Anekdote jetzt aber. Reiserisch. Ja, weil du gereist bist. Ja, nee, er stellte sich raus, dass anscheinend die erste Klasse beschossen wurde und das Fenster zersprungen war. Und dann kam wirklich die Lüste und sagte, ja, guten Tag, ja, die erste Klasse wurde beschossen und wir haben einen Schaden am Außenfenster und wir müssen jetzt mal halten und die Bundespolizei ist informiert und die kommen vorbei. Außenfenster? Außenfenster, ja. War das wichtig zu betonen, dass sich jemand ein Außenfenster gehalten hat? Ja, weil es könnte ja auch die Schießerei innerhalb des Zuges sein, glaube ich. Das war schon, so habe ich es nämlich erst verstanden, dass eine Scheibe der ersten Klasse kam bei einem Schuss zu Bruch. Ums Leben. War die Formulierung und alle so, okay. Oh nein. Ist das jetzt, können wir jetzt in Panik verfallen oder gleich noch? Sag was, sag was, was ist jetzt hier, was sagt einem die Knicke, wie man jetzt reagieren soll? Keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall kam dann die Bundespolizei und hat sich das angeschaut und so und irgendwie stand dann so wirklich so. Kam die dann plötzlich einfach im fahrenden Zug? So mit so einem Fahrrad, die sind neben uns hergefahren. Und dann sind wir im Bahnhof angehalten und dann standen die da halt so ganz, ich war sehr froh, weil ich habe mir am Automaten Gummischlümpfe geholt, weil ich hatte keine Schlümpfe mehr und dachte mir, geil, wenn wir jetzt hier lange stehen bleiben, an dem Bahnhof kann ich mir noch eine Gummischlimpfe holen, wunderbar, dann stand da die Bundespolizei da und hat sich das angeschaut, so ganz fachmännisch und so. Wie du die Schlümpfe gekauft hast. Wie die Schlümpfe gekauft und dann stand da und so, ja, und dann so, ja, es kann gut sein, dass der beschossene Waggon ausgewechselt werden muss, aber so gut, dass man das ständig betont, beschossen, die ganze Zeit. und musste nicht ausgewechselt werden, wir konnten weiterfahren, aber... Als du mir das zum ersten Mal erzählt hast du gesagt, ja, da wollte offensichtlich jemand die erste Klasse beschießen, glaube ich nicht. Doch, auf jeden Fall. Im ersten Mal ist die erste Klasse ja immer an unterschiedlichen Zeitpunkten, an unterschiedlichen Orten des Zuges angekoppelt und ist immer vorne, weil wie kann man denn die erste Klasse in einem fahrenden Zug, ist ja wahnsinnig schwer, irgendwas zu treffen, was... Ich denke, das war auf jeden Fall ein Aufstand der proletarischen Klasse, und ein neuer Klassenkampf steht uns bevor, und die roten Flangen werden gehisst, und das Ende des Kapitalismus ist eingeleitet, und alles geht an die Waffen, Bruder! Mach runter! Ich finde es ganz abgefahren. Ich finde es auch ganz abgefahren. Ist nicht jemand gestorben dabei? Überhaupt nicht. Nee, also ich habe dann... Nicht mal annähernd. Nicht mal im Ansatz. Also ich habe dann auch im Nachhinein so Zeitungsartikel gelesen, wo es dann immer hieß, ja man weiss nicht genau, ob es wirklich ein Schuss war oder vielleicht ein Stein oder sowas. So wo dann auch selbst der Zeitungsartikel das so ein bisschen aufbauschen wollte. Oder vielleicht Gähnen, ein lächerlicher Stein. Ja, genau, lame oder vielleicht einem Vogel, boring und so. Hoffentlich nicht. Mir ist nichts passiert, alles ist gut, aber... Ach, habe ich jetzt gar nicht gefragt. Wie geht es dir? Mir ist... Okay, nee, ist in Ordnung. Ich war glücklich, ich hatte die Schlümpfe. Und von daher... Das ist ziemlich cool. Ja, und irgendjemand hat es getwittert, hat ein Foto davon gemacht und getwittert, und dessen Bild wurde in allen Artikeln benutzt. Und ich habe mich so geärert, warum ich nicht ein Foto gemacht und getwittert habe, weil man muss sich schon überlegen, also man hat ja auch so die Verpflichtung, also wenn jetzt keine Ahnung, Amoklauf in einem Zug stattfindet, kann man das ja einfach mal twittern, so, dass man sagt, so, ja Leute, hier ist was los, so, aber wann geht es los, wann steht man in dieser Pflicht des Bürgerjournalisten, anzufangen zu twittern, wenn jetzt, was muss passieren, dass dieser Threshold überwunden wird und man sagt, Breaking News, hier hat gerade jemand AIDS geheilt, oh what the fuck, Alter. Ja, also wann musst du aktiv das Zeitgeschehen auch dokumentieren. Ja, genau, du hast ja die Verpflichtung. Aber ich würde nur kurz sagen, also mit meinen Noise-Counseling-Kopfhörern wäre ich zwar gestorben auch, aber ich hätte den Schuss nicht gehört. Den Schuss hättest du ohnehin nicht gehört.
Und ich wäre cool, im Sarg hätte ich Kopfhörer getragen, wie cool wäre das denn? Den Schuss hättest du ohnehin nicht gehört, weil die Kugel schneller reißt als der Schall. Ja, aber wenn die einschlägt in meine Wange, hört man das doch, wenn der Schuss in dein Gesicht eindringt. Ich glaube, selbst dann reagieren die Nerven schneller als der Sch...
Weiss ich nicht.
Deine Wangen! Gesäß, Gesicht eindringt. Ich glaube, selbst dann reagieren die Nerven schneller als der, weiss ich nicht, deine Wange, keine Ahnung, du meinst du jetzt wegen, wegen Klangraum oder was? Ich finde es cool, ich finde gerade die Vorstellung cool, dass ich, ich sterbe mit meinen neuen Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörern, dass meine Eltern, oder weiß nicht, wenn mich dann beerdigt, halt einfach sagen, nö, lass dich mal drauf. Ich find's ganz cool, Ber cool, während mich beerdigt, ganz cool, wenn mein Sohn Kopfhörer und Sonnenbrille im Sarg trägt oder so. Ja, das stimmt. Aber dass es sich ein bisschen cooler aussehen. Das könnte man eigentlich machen, sodass du dann auch noch Musik hörst. Und Zigarette. Ja, bis sie aus sind, bis sie ausgehen und die Würmer sich langsam durch die Möskäste in den Kopfhörer fräsen. Willst du verbrannt werden oder willst du beerdigt werden?
Ich will in flüssigem Käse einbeisamiert werden. Ich will in einer grossen Wanne aus Kratzeis beerdigt werden.
Oh ja, das ist auch nicht schlecht.
Das fände ich ganz so cool.
Gibt es so fancy Beerdigungszeremonien eigentlich?
Ja, schon, oder? Seebeerdigungen und sowas zum Beispiel.
Ja, klar.
Wo jemand mit einem Pfeil am Rand steht und dann...
Und dann 800 Mal nicht trifft und dann sagen... Haben wir den Flammenwerfer noch da? Wollen wir nach Hause gehen? Ich glaube nicht, dass das jemals so passiert ist, dass man den brennenden Pfeil auf dem Boot geschossen hat und angefangen hat zu brennen. Ich glaube, das funktioniert nicht so leicht. Ich meine, die haben ja keinen Benzin oder sowas. Vielleicht war es ein brennender Pfeil, der in den Zug... Brennende Pfeile sind ohnehin kompletter Nonsens, aber du hast ja kein Benzin oder sowas. Das ist ja, du kannst ja, wenn du mit einem brennenden Pfeil gegen ein Holzbrett schießt, dann schierst du dich plötzlich das Holzbrett in Flammen. Das ist ja, das ist ja nicht so. Ne, ne. Das stimmt schon. So als wäre das jetzt wirklich ein Problem, das wir jetzt lösen müssen. Ne, ne, aber wenn du da ein bisschen Heu drauf... Vielleicht haben die diese so Knallerbsen dran gemacht, dass quasi so eine ... also dass wenn es drauf fällt, dass dann zu einer kleinen Explosion kommt. So wie Boromir, ne? Boromir wurde ja auf dieses Boot gelegt und an diesen Fluss runtergefahren, wo die ja wissen mussten, dass da irgendwann dieser Wasserfall kommt und Boromir einfach für immer verloren ist. War das wirklich die bestmögliche Art, ihn zu bestatten, ihn einfach ins Wasser zu werfen, indirekt? Vielleicht war das so eine Gondor-Art, so eine Eigenart, die machen wir ja so ein paar Sachen am Stüssel. Die machen ja die Gondorianer. Ich will ja nicht anfangen, aber was die wieder abziehen in letzter Zeit. Jetzt kommen ganz viele aus Gondor hierher, mag ich persönlich nicht so gern, aber na gut, wenn man darf es nicht laut sagen, dann ist man wieder nur das ,,Huist".
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, Mohanist und so, ja. Ich finde ja die coolste Szene aus Avatar tatsächlich, also das habe ich ja auch damals erzählt, als dann dieser grosse Wagen zum ersten Mal aus diesem Wald der Einheimischen rauskommt, auf Pandora, diese grosse, diese grosse, weiss ich nicht, Dampfwalze und dann halt in dem Reifen Pfeile steckten. Und man hat zum ersten Mal gesehen hat, okay, das ist ein Naturvolk, erstens wahrscheinlich, sonst würde man ja nicht mit Pfeilen werfen, und die sind gross, das heißt, du hast halt, die Explosion ist ganz cool, du hast sehr viel davon, weißt du schon von dem Wort. Ja, wir haben ja auch so ein paar Live-League-Videos von Istanbul angeschaut, wo dieser Putschversuch und irgendwie Militärgedönsel waren, wo man auch so einen Panzer durch die Strassen halt fahren sehen und dann Leute, die halt dann mit Holzbrettern auf diesem Panzer einschlagen und sich auch denken so, habt ihr nichts gelernt aus zwei Welten? Ja, oder wo der Panzer einfach instant in die Luft schlägt, wenn das Holzbrett das Panzer berührt. Und man denkt, what, da sind wir nie noch gekommen, wir gehen ja. Ja, ich hau jetzt mal so. Ich glaube, wenn man in so einer Gruppe ist, dann muss man schon was machen. Man weiss, dass es nichts bringt auf so einen Panzer. Du hast die Wahl, entweder du schlägst auf einen Polizisten ein, der dir halt im Zweifelsfall den Arm bricht und dich verhaftet, oder du schlagst auf den Panzer ein, wo du genau weisst, das macht eh nichts so. Ja genau, aber der Panzer wehrt sich auch nicht so direkt. Es sieht trotzdem gut aus, du bist trotzdem dabei und du machst was und Gewalt und für die gute Sache. Ich glaube, ich würde auch auf so einen Verkehrsstellen einschlagen. Nimm das, nimm das, fuck the rules, einfach so. Nehmen an, einfach so auf so eine Wand einschlagen. Hasse dich, Putsch! Ja, genau, so ein Pfeiler würgen, so eine Strassentürz. Einfach um dabei zu sein. Aber das ist auch eine abgefahrene Geschichte. Ich meine, wer sind wir jetzt irgendwie Weltpolitik einzuordnen und so? Ja, wo? Aber es ist schon so ein bisschen so eine Cancel-Palperty-Nummer, ne? Wahrscheinlich. Also er ist ja danach aufgetaucht, dass er halt diese Liste aufgetaucht mit den ganz vielen Richtern, die er dann verhafteten liess und so, wo die man ja nicht so schnell anfertigen kann. Die auch alle Jedis waren, komischerweise. Komischerweise, das ist ganz abgefahren. Und er hat, also dass er so ein Volk gegen sich aufbringt, um es dann halt so Alsostandsgesetze in die Kraft zu hängen zu lassen, ist einfach so ein Star Wars 3. Damit hätte man aber rechnen können, dass wenn solche Leute solche Filme sehen, dass dann sowas passiert einfach. Man hätte damit rechnen können, als man bei Erdogan die ganz vielen Darth-Vader-Plakate in seinem Post in seinem Zimmer gesehen hat. Und diese Stimmverzerrer immer, die sind schwer geatmet. Mein Gott, Sie haben kein Asthma. Doch, ich habe Asthma.
Ja, das ist halt echt, also das ist ganz schön abgefahren. Also Star Wars passiert gerade. Hätte man dem irgendwie die Schlümpfe gezeigt oder so, hätte er ganz anders gemacht. Dann hätte er irgendwie magische Frauen gemacht und in die Menschen geworfen. Ja, oder wenn er, ähm, ja, das war schon das Lustige. Titanic gesehen hat, dann. Ja, ganz doll. Auch, was. Ja, ganz doll gegen Eisberg, weiß ich nicht jetzt. Das muss nicht sein. Nee. Gut. Was machst du heute noch? Äh, ich fahre heute noch nach Hamburg. Zu den Rockbeats. Rocketbinos. Da waren wir auch. Vielen Dank an die Landsleer, die es gesehen haben, gut fanden. Ja, wir haben Montagsmaler gespielt. Es ist so ein bisschen nach hinten losgegangen, ehrlich gesagt. Es ist schon ein bisschen länger her, es wurde jetzt veröffentlicht. Ich hätte echt gehofft, dass es nicht veröffentlicht wird. Aber das Lustigste war, das sind zwei Teile und ich habe den zweiten Teil gesehen und im Kommentar stand, warum wurde der erste Teil entfernt? Da haben wir so, okay, das war eigentlich keine gute Sendung, aber entfernt im Nachhinein, also muss ich geirrt haben, der wurde nicht entfernt einfach. Aber ja, schon merkwürdig. Er wurde der erste Teil entfernt.
In Quarantäne gesetzt, klingt das ein bisschen, er wurde aus dem Verkehr gezogen.
Ja, ja.
Nee, guck dich an, er hat dir Spaß mehr als wir während des Mannes.
Ansonsten herzlich willkommen in Staffel drei des Podcast-Rufos.
Bis nächste Woche, wir geben ab, macht's gut, ciao.